scène de désolation à barr mouthe dans
la région de donetsk
les bombardements russes ont rendu la
ville méconnaissable maria 81 2 ans fait
partie des habitants qui refusent de
partir un missile a pourtant pulvérisé
sa cuisine et son potager n'est plus
qu'un cratère feuillet manade quet ce
qu'ils veulent la russie n'est pas assez
grande pour eux pourquoi tuer vous des
gens je demande à dieu de rendre leur
raison aux russes
même attitude résiliente pour sergei son
habitation a elle aussi été bombardés
lui non plus ne souhaite pas évacuer
tous les membres de ma famille sont
partis il ne reste que ma mère et moi je
n'ai nulle part où aller j'ai vécu ici
toute ma vie
barghout fait partie des villes d'udon
basse actuellement ciblé par l'armée
russe sa chute serait stratégique pour
moscou ces routes donne accès à toutes
les parties du front le président
ukrainien a prévenu les prochaines
semaines seront éprouvante dans cette
zone
mattias guyomar la situation la plus
difficile se trouve dans le donbass
barghout copas n'a severodonezk les
occupants sont les plus actives dans ces
régions acté mais ils ont commis un
massacre et cherche à éliminer tous ceux
qui
personne n'a détruit le dombass comme
les trois reprises ils le font
maintenant neorhino abdul bast acquis à
combler de ses bases à six qui visent qu
de son côté le ministre russe de la
défense semble inflexible
il se dit déterminé à poursuivre
l'opération militaire spéciale menée par
moscou jusqu'à l'atteinte des objectifs
fixés par le kremlin